of course they don't have nine dang
why's yeah how many do you have do you
have we gotta get to the bottom of this
okay mono kinds an impressive booty we
like to go cheek okay I was last married
25 years ago alright my wife who's Cook
was Cody's mom and Tony's mom she died
in a car crash
25 years ago sorry about that last wife
okay then I'm a single guy around I got
lots of girls that I've met I go on
dates I I live alone in my house but I
certainly have female companionship as
part of my existence I love it I'm there
and those ladies that come all of them
are in their late 30s to early 40s I'm
60 years old I know I look 25 but I'm 60
you know I've got these lovely grown-up
girls who do the stuff they trick the
whole thing in like this is this my
granddaughter's next to me and I'm like
my granddaughter she's 15 years old he's
here working so hard I mean next to her
is the lady China and China's barren
like China got here when she was 17
years old as I said 15 I said she's here
since she's 17 she's turned 18 a few
days later here she is she helps run
everything it takes care of stuff she's
my longtime girl my longtime partner
here's this other girl here's this other
girl throughout the series there's the
beautiful girl putting on her makeup
doing looking all beautiful
that's the fiance of the tech guy Robert
Johnson who just helped me put stuff
together who's who's a professor at the
University here the other girl in the
little tiger suit
she's married to a military guy that
it's here in town there's all these
other characters my grandson's fiancee
my son Cody his girlfriend
the girls are those bills all those 20
something's are all the girls of those
20 30 something's I know it's a drag
that somehow there's not a harem in a
tent sitting out here for a lot of guys
to paint that's how I was living but
that's not legal and that's certainly
not what I am pursuing doc I'm really
disappointed I know what happens I'm
really disappointed okay I was with Tim
I was like how does he wrangle these
chicks
what I want to know [ __ ] the Tigers okay
but I thought you had something going on
I thought there was something you a
Hindu spell that you were working but
apparently you're out here just dating
its compute force no three wives you do
have a girl who's your partner that was
true China is your partner there are
there are several partners in the
corporation you know like sexual lovers
you have a lover partner that it means I
have I've got these I've got several
girlfriends that all know each other and
all know about each other and China has
been one of those girls and there are
other girls that are involved so I never
go she ate that let's get down to it
okay how do you negotiate that the
biggest thing there's one line that
really is actually the thing that nobody
wants to have you told her to here
blazing blatant truth I feel this way I
think this way I act this way the thing
that no men want and no woman wants to
hear right that's why they blasted me
I'm the thing by saying all men are pigs
and all women are sheep I don't mean
there's anything wrong with either of
the sexes women end up falling along
with the [ __ ] that we cast out
that's how it goes it's not as popular
now in the me to movement of life that
like you know you're supposed to ask
permission to hold someone's hand I
don't know how I could go out and get a
date I don't know what you're do in a
bar scene yeah to be able to ask a
permission for each step of the way
you're trying to meet girl X but some
madness has ensued I'm glad I'm 60 as
far as that stuff goes yeah yeah our
generation is dealing with a whole
different thing can be kind of a pain
yes yep so okay so it's just truth
you're saying that's how you have these
multiple relationships if you can handle
it just truth and and my next question
is is the reason you're only open three
days a week is because you have to
handle your women the other four days a
week is that what you're busy doing why
why does everybody why does everybody
change their name what is the purpose of
the name is it like no everybody right
Nick and Rob just tank this up Nick and
Robert dudes there's 12 of them here and
none of them were in the film they
centered only on the chicks right they
took it all out all these guys six foot
ten three hundred pounds and their to
Chris who runs all the tech in here is
also like six five and 250 they're in
the way of everything
yeah see those dudes somehow edited
every bit of it out created this girl
only vibe when Cody's the star my
grandson's the other star honor who's
Cody sidekick they look like twins
almost at their cousins they just took
all that crap out of there so Cody's
name is Cody Conners my grandson it's
just some of the people a handful of 25
of us have unique names may try to whip
it around and they got that whiny [ __ ]
on there
you think retards the r-word I didn't
mean to say that have to apologize on
this show
during the 80s that ridiculous whiny kid
comes on who's a part-time babysitter
this girl Barbara Crockett who comes on
like a made me get breast implants yeah
I want to ask you about that
she's hail and talking [ __ ] about all
the names and this and that that chick
comes on as a babysitter he's hanging
out part time she is it infatuated with
getting her boobs done she goes to a
board-certified plastic surgeon
they're not fools it's at a very big
wealthy clinic here in town it's a guy
that we know he gives her the full
talking to about the dramas of getting
boobs you're a teenager I don't know
what you want it's just hard stuff I've
got to have him up with a finance
program where she hates to have the face
for them financially one month at a time
you know or $111 or something every
month is four five boobies he's got him
she hangs out he's only babysitting my
daughter doing nothing else he goes off
to a show with me falls in love with a
guy that joust I got the rides a horse
and all over the Lance a jousting stunt
show yeah it's pregnant by the dude and
runs away with him he's gone another
year or so he comes back he's like yeah
well I didn't have that baby I didn't
stay married I'd like to I'd like to
teach a little more I want to hang out
it was fun and I hang out it was back
she hangs out again for a little while
my young daughter she's a very young kid
herself
he's just playing around with her we
travel off five stars to Africa we
travel to Thailand we travel to the
Bahamas we I'm doing stuff in Las Vegas
he gets to travel and live like a
princess in all these places she lives
in a brand-new house here a barn with
cockroaches this is a pristine perfectly
clean place cockroaches you'd lose your
permit they'd come on you in hammering
you three to four times a month
unannounced federal veterinarian show up
here and white-gloved the whole
experience and always have and they were
when she was here there's the same
people that when she visited it and it
did this rollercoaster ride of up
hanging out here getting pregnant and
running off but she did three times
during her career that whole crazy
process while she's here the people that
were here when she started they're still
here other guys like Rob who was just
here who's now 45 years old a professor
at the University he was here for her
beginning to end he's already a set
wealthy guy living in a beautiful River
home and stuff we own 11 fabulous homes
you see the guy talking about all the
houses we own here on the show blah blah
blah even though the fool is pointing to
my neighbor's houses my neighbors are
coming to me like yo my house doc what
are you doing Mike that guy's a fool
sweet audio track the visual track I'm
like its shipping house after house in a
row we're 50 acres it's probably a half
mile long and those houses woven through
the woods along the water in different
places that have been acquired those
beautiful homes million dollar apiece
homes a number of them backs bar staff's
lived that's where my son Cody lives my
nieces nephews grandchildren my two
daughters 17 of the 25 of us are
directly related and every other girl
that was on the outside in there that
isn't my daughter who are beautiful big
tall girls and my grandchildren who are
of the same ilk are the
significant others of the staff they
just wanted that may said that made us a
cult somehow because your family family
and chicks so many chicks got to be a
cult where the hell are those place hi
why was this girl so willing to lie I
don't understand you think she was paid
she's a little crazy animal people I
told you sometimes these animal person
doc sometimes these animal people get a
little loony you have to admit what it
is is that lunatics are attracted to
animals there we go I'm not attracted to
lunatics lunatics are attracted to an
abaya there is artists who want to have
the artful amazing relationship with
animals but then there are lunatics who
can't get it together their minds are
squashed they can't focus they don't
know what's happening and they find
solace in an animal that they can't it
doesn't judge them it doesn't have any
speech about who they are it's got none
of the social boundaries and stuff that
everybody expects the map they can just
be Looney Tunes around their dog they're
at God for big cats you know the more
cats you have you more unique you are
you know you start saying I got a cat I
got five I got thirty seven with
someone's got thirty seven they're
special every damn time you know they
are you how many cats mm I got only big
Tigers is that holding a big brain a
great a great bearing and intelligence
house cats a little pea brain guys they
are parasitic to the human race tigers
puss snacker Riddick to the human race
you know they've been eating our kind
for a million years those other guys
just live off of us you know cruising
around spitting on you spreading disease
and making a strange connection
I'm not the greatest fan of house cats I
love it
crazy people akin to that unique lady
are there she's the only one 350 kids
that have come here and done through
this apprentice program and helped me do
stuff and and I've had a ton of nanny
babysitters come they interviewed all of
them if they could find
they offered by
for people just to say anything they
could no not a soul came forward except
that crazy nut so I think she might hey
and she lost it a lot of talk about pays
happened I haven't seen the paycheck so
I don't know but she started in on this
whole thing she even called staff saying
haha I've got you guys now you'll be
gone you're going down the drain
she called Rob while he was in Africa
and told him you've had it now bucko you
better find a new job I taken them down
something special going on there you
know I'm not a psychiatrist if I was I
would guess that he would have her own
chapter yeah it just seems so weird that
she would be so resentful but probably a
pretty miserable person right pretty
calm and right really
disgruntled employees and some of the
same people that are there with her you
know have have made tons of money and
had tons of adventure and had tons of
you know prosperity in their life
because of their connection to what's
happening he's way down the list on that
stuff
jealous insane women they do seem to
flow